the skyline of san francisco
looking more like an image from mars the
orange glow from
wildfires burning miles away shrouding
the city's landmarks
the smoke blocking out the sun the
middle of the day
felt like dusk and it is unnerving
i was wondering what time it was and
then i looked outside and it looks like
doomsday
i mean you could tell something is
horribly going wrong
and as far as going to work and
breathing in
all this this pollution is definitely
not
healthy for us as in the bay area it
feels like the end of the world
it's pretty scary
i mean i'm a lifelong californian and
it makes me weak for what we've done to
my poor state
and those fires continue to rage across
the western united states
driven on by strong dry winds burning
more of california this year
than ever before and to the north in
oregon
an unprecedented number of fires
destroying some whole communities
it is the speed with which these fires
spread that's especially alarming
the people who lived in this
neighborhood had barely any time to
escape
sheriff's coming through going level
three get out
get out and uh yeah grab some papers
grab some papers and stuff through it
this is it this is what i've got
some didn't make it out deaths have been
confirmed in a number of states
and officials say that number will go up
we expect to see a great deal of loss
as a result of these fires both in terms
of structures and in terms of human
lives
it as i mentioned earlier could be the
greatest loss
in human lives and property due to
wildfire in our state's history
this map from oregon's office of
emergency management shows what they're
dealing with
dozens of these fires all across the
state and many of them still
burning largely out of control thousands
of people have been told
to leave their homes and head for safety
and officials warn that the changing
climate means what's record-breaking
right now
is just a glimpse of what the future
will look like for these places
greg milam sky news los angeles